okay good afternoon I'm Evan so it's my
pleasure to be here
um so I'm going to talk to you about
more about product design in this space
uh your aspiring entrepreneurs so I hope
uh you know one of the most important
thing is entrepreneur is to understand
your consumers understand how you serve
them and understand the technology that
impact your
product and your consumer so
um so this is uh first time doing this
talk and it's going to be a different
format I hope you participate in case
with me today so I'm not going to bore
you with details I'm not going to go
into a lot of details uh what I want you
to do is engage with me and so you know
participate think about
you know what as you once you you're
done with this class as you go out into
the real world pursue entrepreneurial
career what kind of products you want to
build how you want to serve your service
your consume your customers
um and I believe that's the best way to
learn uh because in this space there's
so much
painting assumptions conventional
westerns and years later we what we have
accomplished is this industry is to be
frank very little it's really enriched a
lot of
early adopters
a lot of djans created a number of
casinos let's move beyond that so really
really want you to
think activate
um you know and and see if we can learn
something from today's lecture
so the thing I'm going to focus on is
tokens
token is the fundamental building block
for crypto for web search
um
you know raise a hand if you want to
share your thoughts when people talk
about tokens you know what image comes
to mind when you think about it
anybody
yes
okay it could be a currency
anybody else
at a casino a trip as a casino can
be a token anyone else jump in right so
by and large in this space when we talk
about tokens there's two things right
um it represent assets of some sort
right it could be native right if you're
using ethereum is a token
uh that's you know the people try to
have different categories of that but
but they're all tokens
um it's money you know it's some sort of
security because you have ownership in
something SEC will love this definition
everything is security but you know they
are actually security tokens uh aft is
an example of a token
right it represents ownership in
something right jpeg Arts music whatever
utility right proof of membership token
gated economy that's example of utility
token
um it can be a ticket right people are
thinking about disrupting changing the
ticketing industry with tokens right a
different way right more easy to
authenticate right so that's an example
voting power right so if you have a
governance token in your swap you're
supposed to be able to change how
uniswap team
you know where they launched their next
instance of uniswap what they support
what they do with their tokens whatever
lots of things what they do is treasury
so by and large these other two assets
and utility
um they capture value
they're static and immutable that's
that's good right it's because they once
you create them they don't change
they're there right you have
writes this number votes to change unit
swap that's going to stay with you
nobody can take away from you until
unless you trade away so it's very
efficient median of exchange median
value
um it's verifiable so that's the power
of this but it's also incredibly simple
and seeing flexible right because that's
what I want you to think about when you
think about product
and you want to fit this token into your
product
it seems like there's something about
your product if your product inside your
product you have something you want to
represent as asset and you want to fix
the transfer of that asset to make it
oops
to make it efficient for
moving values and assets around and
that's what you do
so nft is another example of this right
so so can we all agree that right now
tokens are very very simple right they
once you create them they don't change
right and they represents a number
essentially right a token is just a
number it's my balance how many ethereum
have how many use one token I have how
many
you know uh whatever swap is popular
these days you know you have or what
about nft aft is basically the same
right the AFT is a attempt by the
industry to create something a little
bit more complex in terms of token
because right now when you think about
tokens there's a balance the capture but
nothing else uh they're all fungible
right but you know if you have one
dollar bill another dollar bill they're
fungible right they represent that same
fees attempt to create something a
little bit more complex a different
complex more complex formal token but
the AFT standard today is laughably
simple it could contains a name contains
a URL and URL point to some off-chain
asset that lives elsewhere so think
about that for a second
that is extremely simple why is that
well because we haven't really figured
out how to use token in products today
right so again coming back to this
discussion I want to engage with you
when you think about creating a product
what province is the token trying to
solve right we just say token represent
some asset that in this product in this
environment you want to move assets
around transfer assets are wrong so like
obviously everybody sort of fall back to
this mental model it's like this is
about financial products right it's a
great great rail for transfer money
around right and we just want to
generalize it for money
to anything that has asset right so you
wrap something of value as as a token
and now you can chop it up into a lot a
lot of different parts right you
fractionalize it and you can transfer
this and distribute this much more
easily right voting power is the kind of
asset as well all these things uh jpeg
is is a is an asset right you can chop
it up and distribute very efficiently
right a ticket is also something that's
something of value you buy it from
somebody else and now you can easily
transfer to someone else so it's all
centered around asset and transfer of
medium transfer here medium of uh value
and median transfer it's all coming
together but it is extremely limiting
when it comes to product design right
you you really really have this thing
that's just once you create it
you don't change them ever right that
just feels like all kinds of limits but
but let's engage right I would love
anybody have here have a idea of a
product you want to disrupt once you
leave here you want to go build a new
company what is it
that's probably you're trying to solve
with this infrastructure anybody want to
volunteer an idea
yes I'm just wondering if it's possible
to use token somehow with like just a
messaging app for example to make it
more secure
so you're more thinking about
infrastructure right you're also
thinking about building block for other
kinds of product
um
a messenger and app using a token to
make more secure
what would you want to capture in that
token
that's a good example let's come back to
that
um
I want you to think about is it possible
today right knowing what we talk about
in terms of tokens and afts today can
you actually capture that
um
right because at a high level the
immutability aspect is very very
appealing right you know if you worry
about this is a highly secure messaging
you wanted to be authenticated
um you know so that that's seems like a
good example but think about is it
possible can you actually do that with
the current infrastructure yes
because everyone can just it's not
unique anymore right and everyone can
like you change the way that data I mean
just
yeah
um why don't you Hash Hash it and store
it elsewhere and for the nft to actually
contain the hash that's what you're
saying
um
I guess is the complexity this is
standardization and what do you what are
you hashing right
image but but then then you need to have
a lot of different standards here right
so you need to have a nft stand there
for an image a JPEG standard you have to
have a different
format or different standard agreement
among all the players for different kind
of product you want to represent
different kind of asset you want to go
aft so I think the you know people come
up with erc721 they want something
relatively General right let's just say
store a blob somewhere Json blob
somewhere you know
the complexity details of the asset
stored elsewhere we don't care about you
know you know we just want to make it
flexible right that's probably why
yeah because otherwise you know
otherwise you know they'll have to
create a lot of different things
um so
maybe it's good to stick take a step
back right I see people having a little
bit challenges thinking about you know
sort of visualize what problem you can
solve with this but let's talk about web
spree for a second right maybe you're
understanding where we want to go first
will help us come up with great product
ideas and then we can have this
discussion again is this infrastructure
is this building block you know
sufficiently powerful for you the
problem you're trying to solve
um
so you probably heard a lot about this
right lots and lots of definitions out
there
um people saying web series just
rebranding of crypto
right A lot of people point to you know
asyncz being being disturbed the one
that started the rebranding
a lot of people talk about decentralized
internet there's definitely something to
it but but then you if you ask 100
people who are not in this class not
studying this what is the centralized
internet means they will say
what does that even mean I don't know
another thing is rewrite and own I
supposedly read That's web one right the
early internet is a very very simple you
use the in the browser to just display
information for people to read that's it
and web 2 is more about
consuming information assets content
that typically are generated by users
Instagram Facebook Tick Tock Twitter
Youtube are all user generic content and
what happens in in web 2 web 2 the
distribution of this asset become the
bottleneck the big company are using the
distribution power to squeeze all the
profit out of the user generate content
and now it's funny right these contents
these applications this platforms are
being squeezed by
the platform that distribute the
applications which is Apple and Google
of the world right so everybody's trying
to squeeze all the profit out of the
product they're Distributing right and
that is the essence of web 2 and that is
the thought behind web stream right so
when you talk about website about
ownership own it doesn't really tell the
story what we want to get the internet
back to is to be a more peer-to-peer
model right an original internet is
about creating highly efficient
Marketplace so anybody can say I can
reach whoever I want then equal in
Playing Field right if I can reach
wherever I want I don't need a big
distribution
centralized middlemen to help me with
the distribution then I have anybody can
be challenging company that is the
essence of web 3 is going back to that
peer-to-peer that coordination let's be
clear these platforms server purpose
they bring customer to
Creator who create content right because
you can't just say I have content
somebody have to bring your customer
they serve a purpose but they don't
deserve to take all the profit out of it
okay so that is the coordination so when
you think about what token is good for
that allow Creator to be part owners in
the platform
they allow them to have more control of
the product they produce so everybody
benefit so Webster is about giving tools
to the next generation of product
builders
this
weapon this building block to build new
kinds of product that's more fit it's
more open it's more transparent
and why is that important you probably
heard stories about
articles about somebody did a tick tock
there's like million views and they mate
five bucks ten dollars right because
there's no transparency
whatever I'm putting into my work
doesn't translate into
the financial outcome I want because
there's no transparency only the big big
players the Mr Beast the Kardashians the
Taylor Swift of the world the heavy
stabbed himself as really really you
know content creators right they really
own their work because they're so big
they can have the negotiation power to
get the turns they want for them for
everybody else good luck let's see if
you can get big enough and maybe maybe
then you have the negotiation power to
have that opportunity to create a
business based on the work
you put in right so we want to move the
internet back to more fear model and the
only way to do it is for the Next
Generation Developers
to build new kinds of products that
change the model change the interaction
model between the Creator and the
consumer and the platform
to be more fair it's a negotiation it's
a more of you know kind of everybody has
a piece of pie more involvement so that
is the only way we'll get the internet
back to where we want to be because this
is not a good direction we're going down
people don't realize it's just how bad
things are the outcome of the squeezing
the profit out of the product distribute
is
the power allies in the hands of the few
players and the smaller smaller players
are getting hurt
that is why customer acquisition costs
are going through the roof people are
suffering small businesses are suffering
because it no longer can can depending
on the Facebook of the world to bring in
customers
the internet is actually seriously in in
trouble and people don't recognize them
right so this is what we're about that
is Webster so any product
should be up for
rethinking it's not just bunch of
casinos or what we're seeing in the web
Street world today
okay what's that mental model what we
should have as a product Builder is what
is a blockchain what purpose does serve
it is a public open and sheer verifiable
database where every asset can live up
right the model is rather than putting
your asset into the hands of a big
company where they put in the private
database and you lost control over it I
put on this open share World database
and I have control over it I know
exactly who uses I know I can take it
down anytime I want I can give
permission to only the certain players
to say okay you get to distribute it the
address you don't get to distribute it
because you're working with me right
that level control the assets is what is
going to be needed to get us into this
this more open and more fair internet
and
one thing is very very important here is
what is the role of smart contract play
the smart contract is the magic here
they replace the function that's
performed by the centralized middlemen
why do you give away things information
to the bank because you trust it they
custody your information they won't
misuse the information
why do you give it to these platforms
same thing trust trust is important
thing you give them control because you
trust them they won't abuse your
information
but what if that information that
function is being performed by programs
then you don't have to trust anybody
right they do the things the custody
your asset they keep us safe
then we cut a lot of friction a lot of
middlemen out and everybody benefit from
it right that is important because it
comes down to what blockchains why of
open blockchain is important is
distribute trust you're no longer
trusting a single company you're
trusting a lot of different companies
all these notes and validator that's all
collectively provide trust right so they
balance each other out it's a
coordination problem they all want to
profit from it and they also want to
watch out for other people who try to
abuse their power so that coordination
is important so blockchain has three
jobs
it should allow you to model any kind of
asset you want and control manage
ownership right I have my own set what
is the ownership do I give the ownership
away do I share it if I am a Creator do
I put it out there say go ahead leverage
my asset you just have to pay me a
royalty then you can build derivative
product on top of it or do you want to
apply control only I or these white list
of people can use it right you should be
able to model any kind of ownership
should be able to model any kind of
asset you should be able to manipulate
asset programmably with smart contract
and then finally you should be to
process the transaction efficiently
which I'm going to talk about because we
all know blockchain today cannot do that
well they're very very inefficient but
let's focus on the first two
so coming back to early discussion
which have established you think about
it they failed the first job you cannot
create any kind of asset you want the
infrastructure the building blocks super
basic it's a token it contains the
balance you know it represents something
that's simple and flexible right if you
think about product you want to build
they're much more complex software today
is so complex let's just take gaming for
example right any kind of things any
essay if you imagine anybody here
playing games
yeah a lot of people right vast majority
of people in the world play games right
you can easily imagine a lot of these
games where you put a lot of your time
in I say I want to own that right that
character I grow from level one to level
100 I want to own that and think about
that character what is that contains
lots of information
attributes experience what if I have
this magic sword you have a magic sword
this guy has a magic sword all start at
level one but you have used a magic
sword take down the boss
that should be worse 10 times more
is a history attached to the asset the
history is what make the asset worth
more
can you use the existing model
the infrastructure to do all that no
tokens are too simple they don't contain
enough information if you want to use
nft the information is left elsewhere
off the blockchain
think about for the second
it's locked through the smart contract
the Smart Country allows you to do
certain things and nothing more
the assets also live elsewhere the
details asset while making an asset and
asset lives elsewhere the small contract
look at them say well they all look the
same to me these are opaque you have
rendered the smart contract completely
useless except for
locking
this building this ownership model is
actually worse than web 2.
you have let's think about a smart
contract minting nft as a vendor you
purchase something of value from a smart
contract and from now on even
transferring this to someone else
require you interacting with a smart
contract if I buy a virtual car from the
smart contract I want to pin to a
different color the smart contract
doesn't know that color you're stuck you
can't do it it's worse
than the real world today
right so you need to have
think Beyond this tokenization model
model complex assets mutate in stand and
compose asset
you don't have the possibility composing
things if each of them all the data is a
locked into the smart contract or
off-chin right they are now modeling the
concept of assets
and ownership really well
so in the how am I doing on time I'm 20
some minutes okay
so we talk talk about this already the
metadata I need to live on chain
right all the information about asset
right just as a piece of Fine Art when
you talk to the final people they're
going to tell you
if you want to have something that
represents a final ownership it's not
enough to say I have ownership in the
phone you have to capture all the
information in the history where has it
been displayed how many times change
hands
right what's a lie you know what's a you
know has it being repaired in the past
has it been you know displayed as
one-way words right all these things
need to be captured on chin that makes
ownership
that makes something an asset if you
don't have the information you don't
have the ass don't have the ownership of
the asset you need to have freedom of
movement
right when I buy something I'm not
always have to go back to the vendor if
you buy a car you don't you have the
choice of not going back to the dealer
to get a service if it's locked in
again you have failed
if you don't have compost ability right
if I don't have ability to use my essay
in ways I have a car and I want to put
freaking laser on my car I should be
able to do that if you cannot model that
you have again failed right token is way
too simple way to dump people been
thinking about using token to build
products then end up building the same
thing over and over again a bunch of
casinos
this token have no utility because they
don't capture history they don't give a
re composability they don't allow you to
to use it in ways that that you have
freedom control that so the only thing
that's good for you is building a bunch
of casinos right you probably have heard
about it right all these
all these swaps and decks and all that
they all adds
farming you know liquidity farming
Casino
amts are the new share coins right blurs
I encourage you to do trading who cares
about you if you care about the art at
all right more trades you get more
tokens and then you sell them right and
then oh by the way we cannot enforce
royalty programs anymore right and
that's open openc everybody's giving out
about that if you cannot perform these
functions you've completely failed
right these blockchains the current
infrastructure completely failed
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
our creation I'm now going to show you
this it's not live but I want to
introduce a concept of objects
just how Real Worlds right these assets
are objects they're complex
you can create them you can Define
whatever the types you want to be we did
this example called copies sort of like
crypto Kitty on steroid
we published a type right this is what a
crypto Kitty is they have different
attributes uh and you you know you can
put hats on there you can put clothes on
there and all that or types
type is not a foreign subject right it's
being
software for a long time that's the
interface that describe what your asset
is
the metadata is completely encapsulated
right whatever make an asset and asset
is captured in a metadata
and the global storage is a sponge
objects it's an object store and once
you transfer object from one address to
another give it away to somebody else
you still retain all the information
retained identity the thing doesn't go
away right you're not locked inside a
small contract right right now you have
this other blockchain the model you're
tying data and the code protocol
together if you try to take the data out
of the protocol has no meaning that is
the wrong way to represent assets
the objects is fully encapsulating if
you move around it still have the same
meaning it's fully composable
and so so you can take them apart if you
want right it models real world
ownership
and access control everything's an
object
right so it has history it's
hierarchical like objects your parents
this relationship can be explicitly
tracked can be modeled in the object
hats clothes and all that objects right
you all have the flexibility to build
whatever you want right that's just like
the real world
everything is composable it may be hard
to read right in this case right we take
this something that's pretty simple to
start and then you put on hats uh and
boots and suits and it's an astro hat
right why is this interesting well
remember we also published the type and
saw the interface we describe what this
object is
so this is important
oh I lost a slide too
um
so unfortunately I accidentally deleted
a slide that's uh sort of the money
slide so what happens is
um why is this important why is the
composability important for a second
right think about the minds what we talk
about with creators I want to put my
assets out there I want people to use it
right this will be a dream if I build
something and maybe a video again or
many another artist pick it up and
utilizing it and pay me royalties
that's called permissionless
composability right we model this and we
allow this to happen as example
um another startup
it's called you know I forgot the name
uh during the campaign during the World
Cup what they did is we put up a
prediction Market
if you get it right let's say Brazil won
you get a little flag
and then once you have the flag you can
put on your Cappy
they never need to talk to us
right we put it out there remember these
objects are all typed the type describe
everything you need to do so they know I
can build something that conforms to the
your specification
and I basically are doing a
collaboration with you right in our case
because this is not a product it's just
example we'll put it out there inside do
whatever you want
you know build derived derivative
product for you care right we saw out
there as a Creator you know the you know
Common Goods just go use it but think
about it if it's uh and actually
somebody wants to you know make a
business out of this creator
you can design this in such a way you
have to say pay a royalty first before
you can build the right products online
I can put a Brazil flag on top of it and
if you pure a small fee then you can
transfer this asset to the user right
now all of a sudden
the put the Creator to create the
original product has a wave you know
building a business right so you can you
can model different kind of ownership
right if it's a video game company and
can say okay I have this asset out there
but I restrict it to only company a that
produce a game that can continue this
asset so when I release my next game in
the series I can reuse the asset before
all I can say these companies are
friendly to me uh like like these days
it's collaborations all the Raging
sneakers right you know you can say
Disney can use my assets or Nike can use
my asset and I allow some flexibility so
now we have the ability to model
different kind of ownership model
different kind of collaboration model
different kind of composability model
right it's very powerful and flexible so
sorry I missed that somehow accidentally
deleted the slide
so I'll come back to this
this is what we believe the new kind of
primitive web Suite forget about all the
buzzwords you hear in the space roll up
is UK this and that Bridges and all that
let's fix the fundamental primitive
token is way way way too basic way too
dumb way too simple we establish you can
only build casinos with tokens
if you want to build something with any
kind of utility you need a better
primitive
something that's flexible and that can
represent actual ownership can represent
something that you take with you
if the smart contract disappeared one
day some the small contract get hacked
that asset may still have value somebody
can write a new smart contract to
service the asset think about that model
the assets fully yours and it's defined
anybody can service it if you want to
right the way you can do it is because
the type type is your specification
anything that conforms to the type
you can write a new program to perform
service on that object
you have flexible ownership models you
can lock it in you can lock in just like
the current model but you can be
permissioned I allow you you to
collaborate with me
or if you pay me you can collaborate
with me or you can say do whatever you
want
right any number of models immutable
When We Touch around this right Assets
in the real world are ever-changing
histories are important things changes
over time
most things in the world are not created
you never touch them certain things make
sense
a lot of don't and also remember
skeuomorphicism never really works when
you move to a new industry new paradigm
doing something new if you continue to
do the same thing over and or just
translate over it doesn't work the early
iPhone products are almost very
skimmorphic a notetaker a flashlight app
for apps it was a definite category
early on only until something is
different clipped
this whole Paradigm Shift same thing is
happening today
chat GPT the technology exists for a
while now it takes example
to unlock the imagination everybody
right so that is also very very
important
so fully composable right you want
object to be able to model relationship
with other objects because in the real
world Things Are hierarchical
right
so we believe this is going to be the
new primitive for web stream
so with the better primitive maybe we
can move Beyond this casino chip
representing assets
and start building better products
so
would love to hear from you
as will be entrepreneurs aspiring
entrepreneur right now let's revisit
that question again what product you
want to change
um
and what can you do with this new
infrastructures or blockchain now you
know you have something a little a lot
more powerful a lot more flexible that
you can use
any thoughts any ideas
or you can ask questions
yes
enforcing royalties where these kind of
like programmable value transferring
like how does that work yeah
well so so very basic
um so the objects have certain
restriction traits right whether you
transfer or not can be controlled so in
theory right any object can can capture
other objects you lose them as chart
objects right so you can build something
in a wrap existing object but if it's
not transferable then it's useless so
you can control that way and say pay me
this royalty and then
this is unlocked and transferable so
there's these kind of you know ways you
can program uh when you define you know
when you specify a type of object right
you can add a method essentially say you
know to you know unlock for transfer you
have to pay me certain royalty to do so
that's you know I hope that does that
answer your question but but reality is
is like that's a fixed speed model I
wouldn't consider that a royalty request
related to a future transaction which
value changes have right well you can
apply the same concept here right you
know it's like uh for example let's use
a very very basic today's nft model
right there's a JPEG you can build it
such a way the jpeg the high resolution
actual asset is unviewable unless you
have
need certain condition
so you can say you know you can you can
program and say you have to uh you know
have to transfer you reset some you know
some fail right say pay this royalty
then you get the right to view it right
these are all programmable basically
yeah
I mean it seems like you're talking
about a paradigm shift here where
currently most of the logic and history
and everything is in smart contracts and
uh we keep like the bare minimum and
these addresses and tokens uh in Suite
you're you're creating more complex
tokens and have a separation I guess of
like code versus object and the theory
is that this or the idea is that this
allows for much more complex
applications and products and assets
um the the challenge here is uh in the
web three space uh
you're you're trying to capture do
customer acquisition customer
acquisition most of the existing network
is currently on on this old model which
is why everyone keeps trying to
interface with uh the UVM chain Etc
by definition you're building something
that
doesn't really interface with and
fundamentally does it and you don't want
it to interface with kind of the Legacy
blockchain technology which you're
saying is very Casino like what are the
applications you think this
like what will that will drive adoption
here right because you can't use this
the existing Network effects of existing
users and existing Assets in in the web
free space so you're building something
that new that is much more capable and
functional where do you see this as
getting customers in interesting use
cases yeah so so the question is
basically right
um the current webs free business model
is basically catering to the existing
liquidity in the system right this is
why ethereum is a popular chain right
because that's where the money is right
with this model do we forego the
opportunity to capture that
you know service of the djans and and
where's the opportunity for new set of
user right this is sort of related but
actually two separate questions right to
answer the first one
you can implement the dumb code tokens
as a as an object with a balanced field
right in our world a coin is just an
object with one field right it's
balanced
um so you can do that so you still have
the same Paradigm you can Bridge
existing liquidity over and then you can
build the same casinos if you want but
build it better for example uh now each
pair can be a separate object right now
touching one object that appears
particularly hot one Affair the the gas
price for all the other pairs is cool
right so we can build a better Casino if
you want right to me you know that's
just a building block right so we're not
foregoing that existing opportunity
whether they will move over from
ethereum world now you have to get get
an incentive to do so but that's that's
beside the quick question the more
interesting question is what other you
can you build
anything that's stifle right so this is
the mental model any application that's
stable right now Maps really really
poorly to the current blockchain model
right because complex software
again coming back to video game Right
video games very simple conceptualize
you can think about that right if I have
a video game of
virtual cars racing games right you know
as you level up your games gets more
powerful because you'll put lasers you
put bigger tires and VA engines and all
that sort of thing right these are
stateful these assets are changing over
time as the game progresses right that
Maps really really poorly today two of
the blockchain today and that's why
you're seeing what's happening in the
gaming you know
I hate the term gamify right because of
fight right right they use the
blockchain for what Indian currency
or incentive right the more work you're
putting they give you more tokens which
has value and you trade for other things
right it's basically their model but now
you can say I just want to take that
asset that's inside this product that's
currently private put on this open
public database
user manual model is just a freaking
large database where everything lives up
and what's a benefit well that's where
the experiments are right if you give
this away to the consumer to the gamer
are they more attached to the game do
you actually improve engagement
does it help with your customer
acquisition of you know is it more
exciting to them and also all these
different Assets Now live on this
blockchain this on oh database there's a
query new opportunity
like this is where the you know the
composability become very very important
right
can I change business model for certain
people right remember right now for the
creators they build assets for the game
they build for that game they get paid
little like you probably heard the boys
the artists got paid very little right
would have been much much better for
them to build a business for themselves
create some kind of artwork put out
there and somebody say I need that exact
asset I'm going to incorporate into my
in my in my into my product right these
are a bunch of experiments nobody really
know what is going to stick but you got
to give them the tools to build try
these experiments right now they just
don't have it right everything is so
basic the only the same thing can try
over and over again and they don't work
and that is the thing nobody's claiming
it's like we got to figure out it's not
possible to figure out it's too complex
right but you have to understand from a
product and consumer behaviors right
what do they want like coming back this
is why I spend a little bit time talk
about what website is
right we want to get this world into
this more equitable
right this you know if I ownership in
the platform does it change if the
consumer have ownership in the platform
does that change their behavior are they
going to be more Royal loyal right
another example right right now we
already have ticketing where we have uh
royalty cards and all that
what does that mean to translate that
Commerce you know opportunity to
blockchain right now people are trying
this but you're doing so in very
geomorphic way right you have aft that's
like a token token gated you have more
rights right it's a very very basic
re-only model
what if it's not read only what if the
more you use the more reward you get on
your car reflects the fact you use them
more right you start half of something
that's not quite skeuomorphic
right this is why right now everything
is Basics direct translation I have uh
you know kind of trading cards I
essentially take the trading card put it
in as a digital phone and putting a in a
product again what if that thing's life
and actually engage with you the more
you use the more changes
right so it's a bunch of experiments
let's be honest right this Webster
hasn't arrived there is not a Playbook
say do this it's going to be successful
it's going to be better Prada
but you got to give the product Builders
the tools right and this is why
you know we really want to engage with
the Next Generation product Builder to
think about right right now I'll say the
technology is not serving the product is
the Restriction the product Builder
restricting the developer if that's not
the case what can we do
any any other comments question yes yes
wait wait wait one second sorry
I think most of the time we talk about
values as you mentioned in the talk we
use Smart contract to record a value
distribute value
um so should we call the value three
because only thing web3 related with
internet is peer-to-peer Network my
phdpr network is uh it's not new it's
have been there for that case and
especially with the emergence of AI hbt
uh people think we should we should
refer to semantic web to web3 so what is
your perspective of this statement
use your question about whether web
Street should be
defined differently as a semantic web or
yeah so like compared to semantic of web
do you think
I think I mean semantic web is I know
it's very confusing there was a
different web stream back in the days
right and now this webstery
um I don't I don't know semantic web
knowing well enough to to make comments
on that right what we're focus on today
is
what problem we're solving right again
this the the problem with solving is
giving the control asset back into the
end users which is the creators and
consumer and make the relationship with
a platform to be more collaboration a
co-owner model and that does that
fundamentally change
the next change your products does it
make the internet better right so that's
the question we're trying to answer
collectively I care a lot less about the
term right call it you know
decentralized internet peer-to-peer
internet I don't actually care I think
semantic web is it's it's another
technology is sort of
orthogonal to this discussion here okay
thank you
this
um yeah
I'm curious for your take on Industries
where the Creator consumer relationship
isn't as important something
places where efficiency is really the
main aim of blockchains what does sui
that Paradigm have to offer on that well
that's that's a lecture for yet another
day which is very very long uh so I'm
going to give you a preview the
blockchain today is a very very
inefficient
um because they construct fundamentally
incorrectly in distributed system you
don't do wasteful work so if you think
about it you're ordering
the blockchain works today by ordering
through doing total ordering of all the
transactions in a block that's just
fundamentally wrong right most of these
transactions have no relationship with
each other so the current model is auto
then and try to parallelize execution
then by rediscovering some kind of
dependency either with dynamic or
you know mostly with dynamic means and
it's just wrong so you when you do ways
for work
um you know you you put yourself in a
very very difficult situation in the
system because you have to keep
everything in memory
right which means you're forcing into a
very very large you know kind of big
machine with a lot of sheer memory you
can only skills with Moore's Law right
so you're dead right so uh blockchain
today is a highly inefficient uh
and and and it's just be around and also
the way to address scalability is not
really coming from a product Sentry
point of view why do you want to solve
scalability
you really should be thinking about
elasticity of supply and demand that is
a problem you want to solve today if you
use
Facebook Tick Tock this big big web 2
infrastructure or you building on Amazon
all that you don't ever think about
they run out of capacity right because
capacity is elasticities
web Suite has to be the same otherwise
you'll never be able to build products
right imagine you're building a product
on ethereum
in some and it's how many loans doing
well because you build great product
boy do a land sale
guess what's happening
your chance fees Spike by 100x same
thing with polygon right just Google
polygon sunflower
your business debt for that period of
time you may never recover right so
long conversation that we had another
day that's a whole technical lecture for
another day uh the blockchain today are
very inefficient because they're solving
the wrong problem uh they're doing Rob
and all that are trading off
composability which already doesn't
exist today really
for very limited scalability and and the
casino gets rebuilt on every single roll
up it's it's a long story so I don't
know if I answer your question but right
now there's no good answer because
um you know we also
our data models will solve that problem
but but I won't have the opportunity to
go into a lot of details
but the only thing is that we do
causation ordering rather than total
ordering so it's not doing wasteful work
awesome Evan thank you so much guys we
have pizza and you can you're welcome to
hang out and uh Evan can save for a
little bit in chat uh uh but again thank
you Evan uh really appreciate the
discussion on like rethinking
fundamentally the architecture of
decentralization
thank you for having me